[Music]
I've got you
this is the alarming end to Millie's
first ever Night Out distressed and
disorientated after she says she was
drugged
I think it's probably one of the most
disturbing things I've ever witnessed
literally in my whole life
it was a shock for her mother and just
as frightening for the teenager I've
never felt like that in my whole life
I've never ever had a fit like my eyes
go like that I was so so panicky I'll
say to the nurse what what's going on
what have they given her
and they didn't know they just said we
see this a lot
a disturbing thought for anyone at 18.
million her friends had been dancing the
night away she'd taken a couple of sips
from a drink offered to her by someone
she'd been chatting to but almost
immediately began to violently vomit and
shake uncontrollably
her first night out will be her last for
a while I would love to go out again but
it's like your my anxieties are no just
don't don't because you can end up in
that again but then
it is worrying very worried and I don't
I I wish it just didn't happen because
now every time someone invites me out
I'm like
I no I'm okay I I don't really want to
her mum Claire is just as traumatized
absolutely destroying it
I feel anxious every time she leaves the
houses
I just feel generally unwell I went into
work Monday broke down and I had to come
home I just couldn't focus
the family lay no blame with the
nightclub Millie is grateful she's safe
but the what if questions linger what if
her friends hadn't been there and what
if she hadn't been taken to hospital the
venue are working with police who are
invested
Millie wants this video to serve as a
warning this was a night to remember
that they all would rather forget
ashnaharanag Sky News in Essex